So if you're a facilitator or a teacher, what is it you're doing?
You should understand this is an adapted version of the Lean LaunchPad curriculum
that is actually for post-Startup Weekend events.
That is, it comes after students actually sit through a Startup Weekend
and kind of raise their hands and say, "Hey, we'd actually like to learn more."
"We'd actually like to take this team we've built
"and actually figure out whether we could put together a startup."
This is not a full semester class and not the full version of the Lean LaunchPad,
but these teams will learn a tremendous amount
in the weeks that they will be spending with you.
This helps fill a gap between the Startup Weekend and the next step
that most entrepreneurs think they should take, which is commonly seen as an accelerator.
So the goal of the class is twofold.
Number 1 is we're going to teach customer development.
We're going to give the attendees an immersive and experiential course
and a methodology that they will remember for the rest of their lives.
It's a big idea.
We're going to teach them customer development and give them a methodology
for the rest of their lives.
2 is we're going to teach them team development skills.
Remember kind of graduating from the Startup Weekend to the startup next phase,
this is still a dating phase.
We're going to give them an incredible experience for their team,
but we're also going to stress test them.
This is not just sitting in a class and doing presentations.
Our opinion is if we could blow them up now, if the teams will fail under pressure,
it's better to have them fail now, and it's even better that they learn it's not an optimal team
and what the dysfunctions were now before they take any money
versus when they've spent a million dollars and they're 2 years into it.
So those are the 2 goals:
Teach customer development with an immersive and experiential course
and enhance and expand on team development skills.